[Music]
clever use of logo imitating premise but
how many irritated employees had to deal
with impatient assholes coming out of
the theater saying the movie was messed
up Universal equals not giving it about
the common folk also 52 seconds of logos
and Comcast totally get the previews
have scenes all the time that don't make
it in the movie however the use of into
club was such a huge part of the trailer
for this movie including implying that
it was a song trees phone kept playing
it's quite simple that the actual song
in the movie was this bolt discount
Joshua Jackson does this even a rude ass
person like this knows there's a chance
the girl could still be here or that he
might be asleep or that he's not even in
the dorm room right now global warming
tree is a dick to global warming also
ladies and gentleman tonight the part of
Ned Ryerson will be played by hold on
let me look this up sorry Internet slow
to nail in creole i probably
mispronounced that ladies and gentlemen
but anyway enjoy why would this one
patch of grass need these sprinklers
aimed in the same direction and why are
those the only sprinklers that came on
in this entire area of campus even
though this movie has zero to do with
fraternities movie still has to show
that frat guys are dicks because you
know college movie also though movie
clearly sets up broad moments so that
she will realize she keeps waking up on
the same day but one of the chances
she'd be accosted by someone with a
clipboard witness what couple Nikki here
at car alarm and see a frat pledge fall
over in the span of walking 100 feet in
her returning in my text suspect roll
call starts four minutes in meet Tim
also did he knows she'd be doing the
walk of shame from another dorm room
this morning so he could meet up with
her right here she was clearly confused
as to where she was when she woke up
which means this is probably not the
route she takes every morning across
campus I mean who takes their first
safety subway not long oh man I was
hoping they talked for another five
minutes so that she could finally dust
off some of her old Jared jokes also
rammed your tongue down Nixon's throat
right in front of Danielle God but she
was so nice to me this morning
you mean literally five seconds ago
right you just talked to her in the
previous scene that's kind of a weird
thing to say when the conversation just
happened to really think you keep it a
secret from me
how did you find out driver's license
considering the number of creepy friends
and or former dates tree keeps around
and her ability to get blackout drunk
I'm more surprised this will be the
first instance of someone trying to
murder her also considering the
sorority's view on fatty foods
why did Laurie think this was the best
way to deliver the poison favoring her
to me no hope you don't care who changed
the ringer or why that was brought up
because the movie sure doesn't bring it
up again sorry I'm definitely the killer
face and is that chocolate milk I see
I'm sorry but I'm not the least bit
sorry for Becky I mean was that
chocolate milk on her tray what an
asshole
get with the program Becky hi I didn't
know where you live so I stopped around
campus all day knowing you'd show up
eventually so is sex stable it's a mess
right I think something like this is
bound to have some pretty serious
consequences you're right it is you're
right it's none of your business cliche
damn how many times has she this dude in
his office to be able to kick this chair
directly underneath the door handle like
that I mean I probably attempted this
maneuver over a thousand times in the
past but no matter how many times I
tried it I failed and my girlfriend
walked in on me masturbating anyway
don't get anything on it please you mean
like Nixon Nutter Butter Wow how's it al
oh come on you would never go near
Nick's Nutter Butter it's too fattening
[Music]
the most unbelievable thing in a movie
that's main storyline involves someone
magically reliving the same day over and
over is that every person on this campus
seems to know the exact path tree we'll
take every time she walks anywhere I
help other than the Groundhog Day thing
this movie isn't supernatural so how did
this music box start back up for some
reason tree is immortal and will get all
the chances she needs to solve this case
we never figured out why Phil Connors
relive the same day over and over so why
should we here sometimes God gives
assholes 800 chances to get one day
right I read that in Ackley's he asked
these one-time coincident it's the same
day there's no way that tree's timing
would be the same she clearly got up and
ready quicker than she did the first
scene of this movie there for Ryan is
busting through the door probably 30
seconds before he did on the previous
day keeping that previous time lapse
theory in mind it's not possible she
would greet the same pervy dude the
protestor the sprinklers and the frat
pledge drop all at the exact same time
she
previously she should be ahead of all
these events and no matter how quickly
or slowly she leaves the dorm room in
this movie these events always occur in
the exact same way it will take at least
five days for tree to stop being racist
right now did you learn this from the
matrix
since when does deja vu feel like this
where the entire morning is the exact
same thing you just experienced even if
you're not ready to admit that it is the
same thing by the way what college has a
baby as their mascot how fearsome is
that okay guys today's game pits the
dingoes versus the babies the dingoes
are especially fearsome this year so I
don't want to hear anyone cry in the
dark if this game gets out of hand you
evil angels I miss breakfast we all miss
breakfast Becky the first time this
happened Daniel said what is breakfast
Becky I'm all about the ripples in
space-time causing changes but this is
the exact thing Becky said last time to
Danielle and nobody outside a tree has
changed their dialogue until now it's
normal for a young girl to have feelings
for an old man Jesus they were like
three seconds into making out before his
wife showed up last time now they have
time to go through a whole conversation
tree having a dead mother who shares the
same birthday is very sad and could
explain why she acts so weird and
hostile on a birthday however the movie
indicates this is how tree acts every
day so this side story adds nothing to
the movie by this point how does she not
know she's reliving the same day sure
it's far-fetched I'd probably think
there's no way this day was happening
twice in a row but after being able to
predict the future a few times today
I'd probably rethink my path to the
party and maybe not even go to the party
killer apparently didn't have a back-up
plan if tree chose not to approach the
creepy music box they need to teach
slasher 101 at this university we find
out in a minute this is a surprise party
who does surprise parties like this
first off they tell tree that there is a
party but then they shut down everything
and make the frat house look abandoned
it's a wonder she even went up to the
door this place looks like the collector
lives here
none of these people bothered screaming
surprise and turning on the lights until
after tree had time to punch this dude
in the face guys are playing poker at a
hot girls birthday party rather than
finding some hot girls to play poker
with and all that this double entendre
implies 4e
she said she'd be here between this and
the weird focus on her having to do a
double shift at the hospital movie
Telegraph's lorry is the killer from the
get-go good thing tree is distracted
with her back turn long enough for Nick
to get killed
also it's crazy convenient Nick is
blaring loud music so the tree can't
hear this baler so you can hear now
that's all yeah zero chance the killer
could break the big areas of glass above
and below the piece of wood and get in
if lorries intention was to have tree
eat the cupcake in the morning and die
from the poison then why did she also
have this car isn't this just unneeded
evidence that could point loys direction
if trees death comes under any suspicion
mind you the killer has the remote but
the TB randomly turning on and off is
and conveniently showing information for
the viewer to understand future
shenanigans is so scream 2 that I'm
sending this okay fine lorry was in the
bathroom the whole time but how did she
turn the TV on and off from there did
she drill a secret remote control hole
in the bathroom wall also why did she
wait so long and at this point tree
still has the poisoned cupcake and has
shown every intention of eating it on
this particular day so Laurie is acting
like a killer who knows tree isn't going
to eat it
hey have all the days of your life what
makes this day special what gives this
day meaning it's your birthday how would
you know this from a ringtone sure it's
blatantly singing it's your birthday but
who would actually change the ringtone
on their birthday especially when the
night before she was blackout drunk
whoever's killing you knows it's your
birthday good thing tree had a suppose
at one night stand with encyclopedia
brown you were wasted last night I was
afraid you're gonna fall or choke on
your own vomit like Janis Joplin
approximately 67% of meet cute moments
stem from mentioning Janis Joplin dying
on her own vomit
I was Nick ever even on the suspect list
before she started this list he had
already been killed on one of her other
death days is this guy seriously about
to jacket to gay porn but the blinds
even remotely cracked open and he thinks
he sees somebody at the window for a
second but continues that dolphin
flogging ritual unimpeded
why did tree bother to get the
night-vision goggles and camouflage her
face if she was gonna add the bright
pink highlights no seriously how does
Laurie find tree everywhere she goes
she's
stalking her or else she would have
killed her way before this what dream it
makes zero sense that Danielle would
have the black envelope and movie never
bothers to explain why she does
gotta love those bus drivers who see two
women fighting in the street and think
you know what my horn will get them out
of the street before I run over them
yeah and that's much better than putting
on the brakes pervy Mick perverse encima
have lost his sunglasses that he's had
on all the other days this movie is
pg-13 also you know what would have been
really fun seeing the reaction of Carter
and his dumbass roommate Ryan when she
walked out of his dorm room naked
totally sucks what so tree has to tell
Carter this story every day which means
if they end up together she's going to
have this relationship with Carter that
she's built up in her mind that Carter
hasn't and he will have no reason to
believe that any of this actually
happened the power of boners can even
make you forget potentially psycho women
claiming to have literally live through
the plot of Groundhog Day
while Gregory is in no way the killer in
this movie he decides to act like one
during the blackout for absolutely no
reason at all I just got these back from
imaging these are signs of major trauma
technically you should be dead doctor
cheats on his wife would be amazing at
cinemasins also this is a really
interesting plot point but it brings up
more questions than it answers if she's
been suffering every bit of trauma then
why is she only now having to go to the
hospital
she's been stabbed a few times drowned
and knocked over the head and the movie
never brings this up again also also if
you're going to do this you should at
least make it matter or explain it more
which this movie never does this school
must make a small fortune on the school
mascot masks since every fucking person
associated with the school seems to have
one also even if dr. Butler did choose
to buy the mask for whatever reason why
would he leave it in his desk drawer in
what seriously looks like a secret
compartment welcome to Bay field
University Hospital in which no nurses
make any kinds of rounds at 9:30 p.m.
and any asshole can walk around the
halls unobserved this movie stole
Hospital protocol from Halloween to if
indeed Laurie plan to kill tree because
she was fucking Gregory then lawyer was
in love with him and thought she had a
chance with her out of the way why would
she do this
trees hit the button on the keys several
times now and never change position yet
the car magically beeps in the nick of
time I'm pretty sure this wouldn't be
considered hiding
looks like tree went to the Independence
Day school of celebrating too early man
how do those cars make noise only once
they've appeared on screen must be some
sort of new feature for psychopaths
looking to buy souped-up 4-door sedans
killer is coming from the opposite way
tree was even though they both came from
the same location happy deathday Tokyo
Drift she brought the fucking cupcake
did she think that when she chased down
tree like a madman she'd be able to
force-feed her this also looking past
that lorry knew exactly where tree was
going when she left the hospital why
would she have the candle and a lighter
or matches with her when she had every
intention of stabbing tree not to
mention the lorry would have no clue
that tree would be conveniently stuck in
a cop car with gasoline pouring out of
it
does that candle land right in the
middle of the gasoline oh hey bro
silence okay I gotta give it to Jessica
Roth's performance in this movie it's
truly the best thing about it if tree
has major trauma and scar tissue from
all her stab wounds and shouldn't her
body look kind of like Deadpool right
now any questions yeah why was it
morning a minute ago and now it's nearly
nighttime in the next scene that Ewan
Carter part for the rest of the day
without explaining why you can predict
the future don't you love those movie
TVs where it's just loud enough so that
the hero can hear news that is pertinent
to the plot John tombs portion of this
movie feels more like padding than an
actual relevant storyline sure he
supposedly killed six younger girls but
three can't even prove and her flashback
that tooms has seen her she clearly just
sees the cop sitting outside his room
and even the cop doesn't look up at her
also the reporter calls him john tombs
even though in the earlier news report
his first name was shown on screen as
Joseph if the cops body is all the way
on the other side of the hospital room
with no blood around it then why was
there blood on the door window we
learned eventually that Lori gave tombs
the mask and unbuckled his restraints
but why
even if she's hoping to set up tombs as
the killer by giving him the mask how
would the cops even know whomever killed
tree had a mask on and one of the
chances tombs even goes to the college
campus or anywhere near tree tombs is
never even a suspect unless the cops can
place him at the scene of the crime the
only way this works is if tree randomly
goes to the hospital litter Laurie would
have no way to know what happened also
the majority of Laurie's actions only
make sense if she too was reliving these
days or knew the tree was which the
movie adamantly states she's not Carter
machina nice gesture and all but now
Becky has no beverage tree the vampires
lair he's going to escape go get help go
after tree put a knife to that cops
throat and told him to get help the
local police and hospital security must
really be having a busy night with other
law breakers considering they're holding
a serial killer here
Jim figure out how to tune a free I was
tree even back at the sorority house
even if she somehow wasn't arrested
after assaulting a cop I'm pretty sure
she'd still be stuck at the station all
night answering questions how does
Laurie magically know the tree is going
to eat the cupcake on all the other days
she was forced to kill her in other ways
and so far today she hasn't tried at all
thanks last night
trees Holmes Ian's realization here that
Laurie as the killer is awesome but I'm
sending this because Laurie is the worst
slasher killer this side of Rebecca
Gayheart tree needs to work on her
flashbacks she clearly through the
cupcake in the trash and said the tips
line after she did it earlier in the
movie and not on the floors the movie
suggests here also this was the only
time she threw the cupcake away so you
had to find another way
then tooms fell right into your lap for
Laurie to let a serial killer loose and
frame him for trees murder she would
have to have been convinced that tree
was never going to eat the cupcake and
that there were better ways to poison
her this plan requires Laurie to loosen
John tubes restraints at the hospital
immediately leave and fine tree every
single time no matter where she is not
to mention kill tree and hope that John
tooms could have done it this plan takes
away too many assumptions Laurie clearly
puts the mask on tooms which one would
assume she would do on every one of
these days but when tree goes into the
room later he doesn't have the mask off
John's with the police I'm sure they can
tell us we a little they treat us Meetup
you realize that you're talking to a
murdering psychopath right why would you
say this and think that you could just
leave the room but I'm getting into a
fight to the death
hurry I just kept choosing you over me
just all you wanted was a cheap slut
like you cheap slut versus a psychotic
killer gotta side with Gregory here tree
beans ruby Modine in the vagine
considering trees inside should pretty
much be soup now from all the previous
injuries that apparently carry over into
the next day how does she even have this
much fight left in her Jesus Christ try
explaining this to the car
boys little plot with superlame
poisoning a cupcake really work hapis we
don't eat cupcakes Danielle being
amazing at cinemasins a sign well I'm
sure they found poison in the cupcake
how the tree explained how she knew
there was poison in the cupcake and now
that your bedroom is officially a crime
scene and all yeah and the cops
apparently didn't need you for much
questioning whatsoever you know your
little scenario her last minute okay
come on get moving that Hyundai mmm with
Bill Murray whose memory how can the
person in this birthday video look this
happy and somehow not know what
Groundhog Day or Bill Murray is
all right I think it's something wrong
with you soup there's a dead guy in it
I'm totally having deja vu right now Oh
deja vu is usually a glitch in the
matrix it happens when they change
something he's going to escape go get
help you please stop staring at me like
I took a dump on your mom's head stop my
penis can only get so erect
you're a dumb bitch - hey Safety's off
thanks for the tip look if I remember
the safety that Tommy bastard